Ecuatorianos en las calles para
denunciar la violencia contra las
mujeres
cientos de personas se manifestaron
contra las políticas gubernamentales
ineficaces en torno a este tema porque
el estado nos debe al momento más
[Música]
de 200 y la vida de las mujeres en este
estado hetero normal
asesinada después de ingresar en la
escuela de formación de policía para
visitar a su esposo principal sospechoso
en el caso ha despertado un importante
debate sobre este asunto el incidente se
convirtió en uno de los más
representativos en lo que a violencia
contra la mujer se refiere recientemente
en este
por luchar contra este gobierno
feminicida transfemicina que cada vez
nos mata y viola a nuestros derechos
porque a nosotros no nos cuida a los
policías nos matan nos Asesinan día a
día en Ecuador una mujer es asesinada
casi a diario
la vida de una forma
cruel antes en el proceso sea
transparente sea Y que caigan todos los
que tenga que caer según la fundación
aldea asociación latinoamericana para el
desarrollo alternativo se contabilizan
hasta el mes de junio al menos 206
feminicidios